note la unión europea se prepara ante un
posible corte total de gas ruso con el
aumento del enfrentamiento político
entre rusia y occidente y a medida que
crecen las sanciones para moscú al menos
una docena de los miembros del bloque
europeo ya se han visto afectados por
reducciones o cortes totales ahora el
plan es llenar las reservas subterráneas
del gas europeo y trabajar en un acuerdo
unido para evitar un caos antes de que
llegue el invierno
he mencionado la inversión en energías
renovables he mencionado el ahorro de
energía que es un pilar importante pero
en el peor de los casos tenemos que
estar preparados y esa es la razón por
la que la comisión está preparando ahora
este plan de emergencia todos los
estados miembros tienen planes
nacionales de emergencia pero creemos
que es muy importante tener una visión
de conjunto europea y un enfoque
coordinado ante un posible corte total
del gas ruso
otro de los temores es que el gasoducto
nord stream 1 que va desde rusia a
alemania por debajo del mar báltico no
reanude sus operaciones luego de una
parada de mantenimiento programada para
el 11 de julio es por esto que el bloque
espera que los almacenes de gas natural
de los 27 alcancen al menos el 80 por
ciento de su capacidad antes de
noviembre que prohíban el 90 por ciento
del petróleo ruso para finales de año
bloquear el carbón ruso a partir de
agosto considerar sostenibles las
inversiones en centrales nucleares y
causar una reducción de 850 millones de
dólares diarios en las ventas de rusia
una suma que recibía moscú por las
ventas de gas y petróleo hacia europa
antes de la guerra la invasión a ucrania
ha llevado a la comisión europea a
diversificar sus proveedores y aunque el
sello verde para la energía nuclear y el
gas es una iniciativa para alcanzar la
neutralidad de carbono para el 2050
algunos expertos ambientalistas y
miembros del bloque europeo no están de
acuerdo y aseguran que estos suministros
siguen siendo nocivos para el medio
ambiente